are you a fan of reading me neither
luckily now books come in convenient
talking picture form and today will fit
two of the greatest novel to movie
franchises ever against each other it's
a battle for the winningest Wizarding
World in the world as Harry Potter and
his Hogwarts gang take on the
middle-earth alumni from Lord of the
Rings scared Potter yeah wish we're
lining up the entire franchise is on the
battlefield here and that includes the
prequels whoo I usually make sit at the
kids table
not today here's how we'll determine a
winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
characters and then I'll do a wild card
round before I unleash the verdict
rendering to all you muggles out there
spells will be cast names will be
mispronounced and dwarves will probably
run out of breath what did I breakfast
I've already had it we've had one yes
what about second breakfast box ah
I know seven magic rings aren't cheap
and I'm sure tuition at Hogwarts might
involve some serious student loan debt
but I'm pretty sure the worldwide
box-office tally if either of these
franchises could cover the bill you're
ready to hear about a ton of bread how
about twelve point two billion dollars
that's the total worldwide hall brought
in by the ten films in the Harry Potter
franchise eight movies plus the two
fantastic beast movies because the Lord
of the Rings films tapped out at six
we're not expecting them to compete with
12 bill but they still raked in seven
point eight eight billion dollars across
the globe making for a better per film
average than Harry if we just take the
classic Lord of the Rings trilogy versus
the proper Harry Potter catalog as in
dude actually shows up in the movies
team Hobbit edges out team Gryffindor
with a worldwide per film average of one
point five six billion dollars to one
point three three billion dollars I'd
take either amount of money
those average numbers intensify when we
look at the prequels each franchise
spawned fantastic beasts those movies
boasts a worldwide per film average of
550 million dollars while the three
Hobbit flicks can brag about averaging 1
billion dollars per movie yes you heard
it here first
all 6 Lord of the Rings films have
grossed at least 1 billion dollars over
the world adjusted for inflation so just
imagine how much money those flicks made
in middle-earth is that like a
documentary for them
our Peter Jackson's movies like The Last
Dance of middle-earth it's amazing how
popular and Bank friendly the Lord of
the Rings films have been since the
Fellowship of the Ring kicked us off way
back in 2001 but also watching a film
franchise in 2001 was Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone and since then JK
Rowling Wizarding World has made 9 more
movies all of which can at least be
considered smash hit blockbusters um
bloody you and despite the fact that I
fall asleep within 10 minutes of each
one of those fantastic beast movies that
prequel franchise is still looking to
make more movies and yes I know Amazon
paid a report at two hundred and fifty
million dollars to get into JRR
Tolkien's world with new streaming
adventures but if we're just going on
box-office I'm leaning towards Harry
Potter what's that
who sold more books okay let's make that
the deciding factor in the box-office
reading tomato breed Harry Potter has
sold 500 million books and despite a
decades-long headstart the Lord of the
Rings / Hobbit novels have sold a mere
250 million books it's not often a
worldwide total of almost 8 billion
dollars losses you around in the box
office but the Lord of the Rings ran
into a boy wizard buzzsaw harry potter
takes round
well done round two tomato meter slash
audience score it's clear fans love both
of these celebrated franchise and that
claim is further ratified by the Rotten
Tomatoes audience score the Lord of the
Rings entire franchise has a fresh
average of 86% and that's all the more
impressive considering the original
trilogy averages 92% meanwhile Harry
Potter is no slouch averaging 79% for
the entire Wizarding World and 82% for
his eighth movie set brilliant
pre-qualified The Hobbit movies averaged
71% - fantastic beasts 67% and again
maybe I would have liked those movies
more if I wasn't asleep seriously it is
Newt Scamander cast a spell called
melatonin yes I'm primarily upset with
the crimes of Grindelwald which happens
to be the lowest rated film of either
franchise at a rotten 54% the Battle of
the five armies has the dubious honor of
being the lowest rated Tolkien movie
I'll be it's still fresh at 74% so it
would appear Lord of the Rings has the
advantage but let's take a look at what
critics had to say and I like less than
half in the office well as you deserve
they like the movies - and while Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows - can buy
the next round as the overall highest
rated film in either franchise at 96%
the next three films on that list are
the classic Lord of the Rings trilogy
films - Towers is it 95 percent returned
to the king is at 93 percent and
fellowship clocks in at 91% overall team
Tolkien's tomato meter averages seventy
nine point three percent compared to
seventy eight point four percent for
Team rolling just like the box office
round it's tough to call either one of
these franchises a loser in terms of the
tomato meter but around can only have
one winner and this is the time when
Gandalf tells Harry take it Jason Segel
[Music]
Lord of the Rings wins the round and
we're tied at 1
found three euros oh sure I could have
made this category something vague like
characters I usually do but we all know
what these two mythology's hinge on
great heroes and opposing villains now
both stories put front and center
protagonists who may be reluctant to
reach their full potential Harry Potter
is a boy wizard and besides saving the
world he has to grow up and find his
place in said world meanwhile Frodo and
Bilbo Baggins both might rather spend
their days in the Shire occasionally
having too many hard ciders at the pub
but fate had other plans not to mention
other characters Lord of the Rings gives
us more hobbits such as Sam Merry and
Pippin plus a powerful wizard in Gandalf
a wise elf and Galadriel
and of course a follically blessed King
in Aragorn let me also give a nod to
Legolas Theoden Elrond there's a bunch
and if you're from middle-earth and I
didn't mention you I have time
constraints but it also goes to show a
point these adventures unexpected though
they may have been are all about the
team
the film's utilize their lengthy
runtimes to highlight some individual
accomplishments but it's all in the name
of unity look at all the different
species putting aside their differences
coming together and battling to defeat
the armies of Sauron remember that dudes
I
uh so creepy we also had to deal with
witch-king Wormtongue and Denethor who
you never want to be stuck behind a
Golden Corral and then you have Saruman
who is pulling double-duty battling both
Gandalf and Yoda at the same time but if
you like yourself some villains prepare
ye for the foes Harry Potter and the
Sweathogs had to face Voldemort was so
menacingly evil you couldn't even say
his name
hold a moose don't use that name we also
had evil authority figures like
Bellatrix Lestrange and lucius malfoy or
how about his kid Draco bad apple from a
bad seed in addition to our big three
heroes of Harry Hermione and Ron we also
got memorable boosts from Professor
Snape and McGonagall and also Hagrid
I'll give Newt Scamander and his prequel
friends a shout-out here because look
they're trying but I'm hard-pressed to
come up with a real quality contributor
to keeping me awake during those
fantastic beasts but Oh Dumbledore
yeah old young I'll take d door all I
can get and fans have long debated who
would win in a wizard off between all
this and Gandalf hardcore Potterheads
want to will their guy to victory but
it's hard to imagine Gandalf not being
able to lock him down there's so much
danger at every turn in middle-earth our
hero's quest sees them dealing with
Bork's spiders race goblins trolls
mountains walking vast distances where
were you Eagles Balrogs and creepy
creatures with split personalities the
x-factor here goes to Gollum or as his
high-school friends call him Smeagol
he's one of the most memorable
characters in either franchises and Andy
circuses performance capture revolution
put an indelible mark on The Lord of the
Rings about the great duality of the
human psyche it is he a human who cares
weasels photographer however I think the
Swank factor in this round goes to Harry
Ron and Hermione somehow managing to
stay friends and maybe more than that
while battling giant snakes Death Eaters
Voldemort jerky witches whomping willows
werewolf spiders and trolls we have a
cave troll
okay so middle-earth had Death Eaters
too but the Harry Potter big three they
had to deal with them while also going
through puberty don't you hate when you
conquer a whomping willow only to have a
huge zit on your nose the night before
prom in one of the toughest rounds of
all time in the history of versus I'm
gonna award Harry Potter and his gang
the win in round number three most
iconic we're looking for the most iconic
of the bunch and to do that let's start
with some of each franchise's most
memorable moments with Harry Potter just
remember seeing these gorgeous sets for
the first time on the big screen
Hogwarts the Chamber of Secrets platform
9 and 3/4 they all showcase the
imagination of JK Rowling while
immersing us further into this war
welcome Harry to Diagon Alley
it's an accomplishment just getting us
into the theater so many times for one
franchise and it's all the more
impressive but the final climactic clash
between good and evil lived up to the
hype even though I maintain volt or did
not have his a-game that day you got to
give props to Harry Hermione and Ron for
coming together one last time when it
mattered most let's finish this the way
we started with Lord of the Rings I love
thinking about the contrast from one set
to the next the Shire looks like such a
relaxing hippy village and I think
Woodstock could have been an annual
summer tradition there juxtapose that
with the volcanic intensity of Mordor
and then remind yourself that our brave
little soul trying to take the ring
there is from that late 60s Beatles
commune place the Shire crazy walk into
Mordor there's also epic battle scenes
that rank up there as some of the best
action sequences ever put to film the
Battle of five armies is impressive in
sheer scope but I'm talking about the
intimate hand-to-hand combat or in
legless case that hand to arrow to face
combat I love that shot of him in the
rain sliding on the stairs knocking down
baddies like he's Ray Allen draining
corner threes damn it I want sports
again I'm so sorry oh yeah and it
perhaps the most surprising legacy left
by Harry Potter Quidditch is an actual
sport played all over the world
seriously
it's replaced frisbee golf as the go to
college kids sport of our time Lord of
the Rings can't match Harry Potter in
terms of intramural athletic
accomplishments so it'll have to be
content with its incredible run at the
Oscars Return of the King won every
award category in which it was nominated
making it a perfect 11 for 11 including
Best Picture and Best Director only two
other films ever have won 11 Oscars can
he name him oh wait it's Titanic and Ben
Hur don't you
so lots of folks think Andy Serkis
should have been recognized for his work
as Gollum but he'll have to be happy
with that character helping the movies
take a Jurassic leap forward in terms of
visual effects plus everyone has tried a
Gollum impression at a party usually
doesn't go well no I'm not gonna try
both franchises had their inaugural
films released in 2001 as Stanley
Kubrick foretold and while both have
promising futures with prequels Broadway
shows and streaming seasons in the works
it is the opinion of this court that the
Lord of the Rings is a hair more iconic
a thin wispy hair like one of the ones
on golems comb-over it is a precious one
indeed because now we're tied at two
rounds of peace okay may come when the
courage of men fails when we forsake our
friends and break all bonds of
fellowship so once again it's up to me
to step up to the plate and render a
verdict that will be scrutinized for all
time and perhaps the bloodiest battle
yet I'm giving this win to Lord of the
Rings
maybe it's because the source material
came out first or I saw all those movies
multiple times and theaters but it's no
shame to Harry Potter Harry doesn't care
about me he's in New York and he's got
that person child to worry about Joe was
always sold out
ready ready all any of us care about is
what you the viewer has to say so
comment below and type in your vote are
you going lotr or HP together those
letters spell floor so as long as your
answer makes more sense than that we're
good just completing it completely keep
it classy out there on the interweb I'd
love to stay and chat more but I booked
an eagle to come whisk me home it'll be
here now any second never on time oh
wait I'm already home cancel leave
[Applause]